you come from a line of filmmakers no no
I don't know the first one actually in
my family uh okay so I just find it
fascinating that you had sort of this
this business vision along with creative
vision to go to AFM with a script that
was not finished yet Chris and and
already trying to find distribution for
it's pretty amazing
where are you getting that those ideas
from its you know so I wrote so American
film markets using November every year
in Santa Monica California
and when I went there I was in the
process I was still writing Mason
brothers and I had he had two other
projects I was still I to the products
with finished scripts that I was trying
off the ground with with that too so I
kind of have I had a couple scripts that
I'll try out the ground however my my
good buddies in the business um also a
director and a producer he um he
recommended to me prior that years ago
he's like hey you have to go to American
Film Market this is the place you got to
go for being distributors and even not
just that's great networking you got to
go and he was kind of tell me how it
worked and stuff and he kind of mentored
me gave me some advice on how the whole
process works and walking into the
different hotel room suites and meeting
with distributors and stuff so I had
that he kind of pitched the idea to me
and um just this is a business I mean as
that's what it is is creative but in my
opinion small business in his creativity
in a sense I mean it is creative but
it's its business is what it is so you
make a film associate feature film your
goal should be obviously you want to
make a probably want to you know
obviously do what you love and your
passion I would also try to make some
profit off it if you can so it's just
smart to go to someplace like an
American film market or another film
market to try to sell film or anything
you have on your production company
other projects which you're trying to
get started so it's just wise to do that
and yeah I just thought like I was
thinking was a business mind you know
that's that's what should be done and my
friend was told me to do that so I did
it
do you see other filmmakers around you
maybe the ones you went to film school
with or people that you talked to here
in LA that have that same mindset cuz
some people who are very offended
thinking that their their work of art is
is also a product and I can see how that
would make people mad but in actuality
it's true it's a product right that's
what it is some people I mean some
people have that same mindset but some
people don't I mean some people have
their own agenda how they want to do
things I mean most filmmakers I've met I
mean a lot of people majority lot people
go to film festivals to try to get
distribution for the film most of
obviously are just some type of exposure
so yeah I mean a lot of people have that
mindset but maybe some more than so some
some people treat it more in the
business and then maybe some some don't
there's some hustle harder and trying to
get their film distributed or synthetic
pre-sales deal prior to shooting it so
it really just depends on the individual
I've seen different people do it
different ways but me personally I've
always yeah I think American film market
and going to get some type of
distribution deal and Pryor is important
you